[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Heya.
Today, we're going to talk about
how to build a custom sentiment
analysis model with Google
Cloud AutoML Natural Language.
If you've played with the
Natural Language API before,
you might have seen
that it can tell you
the sentiment of
a block of text,
like whether a tweet is mostly
positive or mostly negative.
But what about for text with
domain-specific language?
For example, let's
say we're trying
to classify the sentiment
of a tweet like, Delta, I
was waiting on the
tarmac for two hours.
That's a made-up
tweet, by the way.
Sorry, Delta.
An out of the box
sentiment model
would tell us this
tweet is neutral.
It doesn't realize that
being stuck on the runway
is a bad thing.
For this, we'll use AutoML
Natural Language to train
a custom sentiment model.
To do that, we'll need
a labeled data set.
Today, we'll build a
model that identifies
the sentiment of tweets about
airlines using a data set built
by CrowdFlower.
To prepare our data
set, all we have to do
is save the tweet with
our labels in a CSV.
The leftmost column
indicates what
we should use a given example
for, like testing, training,
or validation.
The label on the right are
the tweet sentiment scores,
which, in our data set, have
been labeled by a human being.
0 is very negative,
1 is intermediate,
and 2 is very positive.
Within the AutoML
Natural Language tool,
we'll choose to launch
an AutoML Sentiment app.
Next, we'll import our data
by clicking Add Data Set.
Here, we want to choose
Sentiment Analysis.
We can upload the
data by importing it
as a CSV directly
or as a ZIP file,
but I've already uploaded my
CSV to a Google Cloud Storage
bucket, so I'm just going
to import it that way.
Down here by
Sentiment Scale, we'll
tell AutoML the range
of sentiment scores
to expect in the data set.
Since our scores go from
0, the most negative,
to 2, the most
positive, we'll select 2
as the maximum sentiment score.
Now the data is importing.
This could take a few
minutes to finish.
Once data is imported, we'll see
it here in the Text Items tab.
We can click into an example
and make sure it has the right
sentiment score, or
change it if it doesn't.
Notice, we also have the
counts of how many examples
we have for each
label on the left.
We'll need at least 100 examples
per label to start training.
We can begin training a
model by navigating over
to the Train tab and
clicking Start Training.
Training a model can take up
to three hours, so hold tight.
You'll get an email
when it's done.
When training's finished, we'll
be able to see our model here
in the Train tab.
We can see how well it did by
clicking See Full Evaluation.
Here in the Evaluate
panel, we can click in
to see the performance
of our model.
The metrics we care about
are precision and recall.
Up top, we can see
both, but if we
click into a single
sentiment label,
we can see it broken
down for each category.
Precision tells
us, of the tweets
that our model did label
0, how many really were 0?
Recall, on the other
hand, tells us,
of all the entire tweets in the
data set, what percent of those
that should have been labeled
0 did our model actually
end up labeling 0?
Another useful tool is
the confusion matrix.
It tells us how the real
labels of the data set
compare to the labels
that our model predicted.
For example, 91.3% of the
time, the model accurately
predicted that tweets
with the label 0
should have had label 0,
but 26.7% of the time,
it also thought that
tweets with label 1--
those that are just neutral--
should be labeled 0.
If we click on one
of these boxes,
we see examples of what the
model correctly and incorrectly
labeled.
In the Predict tab, we can start
actually using our model hosted
by Google.
We just have to think of some
positive and negative airline
tweets to type into this box.
And there we go.
AutoML Natural Language's custom
sentiment analysis feature
knows that losing your
luggage is not fun.
That's all for now.
Have fun modeling.
[MUSIC PLAYING]